[Music]
you guys remember carmen elektra
she was so hot
i'll never forget a slow-mo run in a
scary movie it's great movie three but
then baywatch is where you first saw the
beauty baywatch like really broke out a
lot of hotties yeah but it's game over
three is where the [ __ ] stab and the
silicone comes out oh yeah
but like pam came up pam anderson came
up oh man
the 90s girls i think were the best the
90s ones yeah i like the 90s girls shots
heavy nostalgia there brook shields
that style don't say blue lagoon or
whatever that movie is uh we wait
oh yeah huh is that demi was that no
that's brook shield
but that was like when she was like 16
or something hey dude what about denise
richards bra oh yeah wild things his dog
i think so was that that video that we
showed up yeah or no you looked up a
video of like a music video it was just
that's it but then didn't it lead to her
from top gun okay never mind
we're talking about her now are
bombshells not a thing anymore
bombshells dude right now they have like
what's her name um now they're like oh
we think that'll make you a good actor
or whatever well they they took a chick
and they like prosthetically enhanced
her to look like pam anderson because
there's no bombshells anymore what's her
name the kit the the chick from uh
that beatles movie um
yeah there's a beatles movie recently
where it was about a guy who wakes up in
a world that doesn't remember the
beatles oh yeah yeah
the the the indian kid right yeah and he
pretended
he pretended to write all the beatles
songs and like she was the lead chick in
that movie she was supposed to be pam
anderson is she used payments in the new
pam and tommy doc
series yeah yeah what's her name like
[ __ ] whatever lily james yeah lily
james there's no chick that's like but
exactly so they couldn't even cast one
they had to prosthetically
looks like because i think they're wrong
i think margot robbie's pretty smoking
she's very strong
but besides her like we just named 10
smokers
there were so many smokers some traeger
grills
we only got margot robbie any other
smokers nope i'm gonna google hot
celebrities so karma the markers carmen
elektra is joining only fans bruh
she's gonna make a kill but isn't she
like 20 years too late no she's 51 so so
it's it's a good idea so she's 50 years
early
she even not use a cell phone she
doesn't she says her manager is working
on that
[Laughter]
she says she can't get past her lock
screen but she's working on it
no she's 50 right she turned 50 in april
what does that make us if we were teens
getting horny for a girl that is a grown
woman she was like 21 22.
that makes that's kind of pedophilia if
you think about it right no because the
affection goes one way he doesn't know
we exist was dependent to us yeah she
doesn't know who the hell we are the
first excuse me
actually i think if she saw she would
like to be disgusted and walk away
no no not me dude
yeah she recognizes you as a human yeah
not anything i used to wear a [ __ ]
red bandana because i had the scare
haircut dude i put a red bandana here
because i like double dragon and [ __ ]
that's tight damn you're so funny
definitely shopping at miller's outpost
you know what i had i had a white
bandana because i was like i'm not a
blood or a [ __ ] that's a statement and i
had a cut off [ __ ] denim jacket dude
that's fire that's gangsta and i wore a
[ __ ] wife beater inside that's sick
yeah i wore wife eaters too and i was
probably about 120 pounds but in my mind
it was 220 you know what i mean
yeah i would drink milk because i
thought milk would just put muscle on my
body just by drinking milk damn damn the
milk works somewhere else am i right you
know what i'm saying it made me [ __ ] a
lot
i came way more i just shoot huge loads
from white to white
adverse effect damn that is crazy what
does she look like now uh she's still
pretty smoky but like a little bit melty
that's that's she says in her only thing
well melty is not
she says i'm smoking but melty it's like
when you put too much botox in and
starts like that's part of it though
when you get older it just starts
melting off yeah that's normal well
that's fine it's part of life dude my
mom's melted
i feel like the melty only happens when
you like add [ __ ] no you're just melting
like everybody's melting everyone's
melting slowly your mom's probably half
melted too oh you talked about my
[ __ ] dude
dude we talked about your mom here no i
don't know my mom's melted
what did they do when they do the
facelift pool thing excuse me face left
pull thing yeah botox they're still
pretty hot
oh that's very [ __ ] you think so
but you wouldn't [ __ ] brittany prime
brittany 2020 2001.
i think you just don't like britney i
don't understand that i don't get this
guy doesn't look like her face moves
much anymore yeah exactly true
apparently she still can blink but not
much else that's what this says can she
still smell yeah she can't really smile
but she can look like she's smiling
through her eyes she also looks like she
might have
just overcame psoriasis or something
she definitely got that like you got
cake look you know what i mean like
it's a little bit more than like a
centimeters thick of the makeup type of
feel for sure a splash of water would
ruin her face but still definitely more
than bangable yeah so she says like you
know if even the sprinklers come on
she's [ __ ] running and this is a
wicked witch of the wedding yeah she's
got so much experience though and she's
like [ __ ] so many people i'm so
curious you know who's the most [ __ ]
the most [ __ ] uh old lady of all
time though i think was dominating no
doctor medicine woman dr quinn medicine
woman when you saw her in wedding
crashers you're like oh
bam she's pretty hot
yeah
who's who's a good good retired old lady
that you can sophia baguera sophia she's
pretty great regardless she's [ __ ]
good
but i don't know are they like 35 but
they play a 45 year old and she's hot
take meryl streep yeah i was about to
say girl's dream bro you've got the
heavies
she ate well
childs definitely could cook you a
[ __ ] dinner
this is carmen electro by the way
look not to disappoint everybody but
recently
oh i'm so disappointed she's 50
something yeah sorry wow
sorry damn it editors can put a
disclaimer because people might throw up
or some [ __ ]
she's gonna make you scorch your mail
bottle hey and she's at the age too
where you could do unlimited cream pies
and not worry do as many as you want
yeah she doesn't have a one surety
[ __ ] went through menopause dude she
said the prince [ __ ] her womb up so
bad that she didn't have one anymore i
thought it was dennis rodman because he
i already
yeah wait where'd you hear that from no
okay you know what's crazy it's princess
prince prince made her like prince
prince put her on yeah and then later on
she got married to dennis rodman right
but like yeah she got famous because of
you know prince helped her career he
built her up prince made her um sleep
with makeup on yeah
and he was like yo don't ever [ __ ]
take your makeup off ever hmm that's
smart yeah
santa's the kind of guy though that will
walk around with frilly socks and bang
the hottest girls prince wears like
seven inch stripper heels yeah and then
he's banging strippers
with their hero
i know he's like the most
playa playboy [ __ ] gonna turn a
straight guy quick dude prince made it
cool to suck your own dick he's a sexual
maverick remember this well he sucked
his own dick yeah prince was sucking his
own dick all the time i know that was a
maryland man and he made it cool it was
him and marilyn manson they would get
together and they would invent this
thing called the pretzel right where
they they don't suck each other's dick
but then they they tie their legs
together like that and then they suck
their own dick intertwined but you're
sucking on your own dick so it's not
good so wait what do you need to do with
somebody else but it's for leverage yeah
like that there you go there you go wait
that's just legit right there am i doing
jiu jitsu right now okay but then it's
like i was like okay but like hey
respectfully you know so we help each
other come down on ourselves there you
go the pretzel the [ __ ] pretzel
that's what he invented
and that changes with the most here that
changed the game by the way that means
you're too tall to pull this off if you
guys remember at the time
if you guys were small enough at the
time some of the manliest men
jean-claude van damme would start
sucking his own dick after that that's
why he practiced the splits
yeah yeah
it's in his documentary he says i i
practiced this these splits so i could
suck my own d that's right yeah he said
it
that's why he was on the breaking movie
you know um if you see one of he's one
of the extras so yeah um
so yeah prince plowed it beat it up good
he said and then um shaq actually ended
up beating me up quite a bit oh really
yeah you've seen the girl that checks
with now she's [ __ ] tiny dude yeah
she's like [ __ ] like oh my god or she
actually five five but jack makes she's
[ __ ] i mean that's really pretty
small for everybody she could be five
eleven and still look small remember
somebody who died from like [ __ ] a
horse isn't that gonna happen that was a
man that was
he was getting [ __ ] by the horse
actually yeah yeah right he got [ __ ]
by a horse what you ever seen that
poster of like how short yao ming makes
jordan look yeah but then how like short
i think shaq makes me look no no no
other way
makes shaq look short yeah and then shaq
makes the rock look shorter yeah i mean
the rock makes kevin hart look short
i think that's the photo actually oh
but no there was a guy i mean dude let's
be honest right like so we live in a
time where who's the cat who climbed el
capitan or um the free solo guy
alex so yeah alex he looks at the
mountain and he goes i'm going to
conquer it right and then yeah there was
a guy 10 years ago who looked a horse
and said yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] sit on
that
thing he's like up in a cockroach one
day they'll make a documentary about me
but alex hall lived and this guy died
that's the difference between the two
but they're both extreme into extremely
hard anybody got anybody else got some
hot takes on some celebrity uh lustful
uh fantasies why you sound like you got
a hot date the meryl streep thing is
actually [ __ ] waiting for the real
thing no just what we're just talking
about right now
pull up a picture
that's what i'm saying it's a hot take i
don't know if you're gonna be down for
it okay i brought this up like a long
time ago i had another job with some
other people and they all looked at me
like i was [ __ ] crazy you are crazy i
was joking this is meryl streep right
here [ __ ]
get [ __ ] used to it no i think denise
richards is hot you think denise
richards that's a hot i agree with that
actually no dude you got to go hot take
that's easy
obviously bangable i'm talking like what
about like junior girl streep is not
good dude
no no no no no honestly though what the
[ __ ] is your name from red two
my hall pass what circle with my wife uh
dame
helen uh helen
mirren
dame hello who's that one she's stacked
bro got triple b
oh you know what's hot cersei lannister
man but she geriatric she old she's a
hippie helen mirror she's actually hot
you know who's old and hot what diane
lane diane lane who somebody's got to
give you don't like diane lane you know
who's [ __ ] stacked nancy pelosi yeah
nate supposedly got some titties
pelosi
she got some big ones
the biggest
all right i googled i googled hair milk
no you didn't google helmet and titties
that's your problem that's why he
laughed and nobody laughed over there
helen murray he's dying dude that's why
nobody left over there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you